hello my name is Nick citizen and I'm
with the iOS team at Wolfram research
and my talk is on using the cloud on
your mobile device and we'll be talking
about the cloud app on iOS Android and
the player app on iOS
all right good afternoon everyone my
name is Nick Zets Minh and I'm one of
the mobile developers have Wolfram
research and I'm here to tell you today
about three different applications that
we offer that you can use to view your
cloud objects on your mobile devices and
even edit them and those applications
are Wolfram cloud for iOS or from cloud
for Android and a new one that we just
launched not long ago Wolfram player for
iOS let's start with Wolfram cloud for
iOS and Android they allow you to create
and edit your notebooks and also edit
and use most of your deployments like
forms and incident API is from your
phone or a tablet computer the system
requirements for iOS is we require iOS 9
or later however iOS 9 support is not
long for this world and will soon be
requiring iOS 10 so if you're using an
older device that only requires that
maxes out at iOS 9 that we encourage you
to upgrade at the very bare minimum the
app will run on a system as old as the
iPhone 4s or the iPad 2 however we do
not recommend this and the reason why is
because those devices had only half a
gigabyte of physical memory and here I'm
talking about physical memory and not
storage space and because they only had
512 megabytes they will easily run out
of memory because the front end requires
around 150 160 megabytes and that's what
just with a blank notebook any more
complicated than that and it's going to
run into memory starvation and the OS is
going to mercy-kill it at the bare
minimum I recommend iPhone 5s or iPad
air or later I'm using an iPad air 2 for
this demonstration coming up if you have
an iPad pro with a 10.5 inch screen or a
12 point 9 inch screen you're in luck
because we support those screen sizes at
full resolution and if you have an
external keyboard either a Bluetooth
keyboard or Apple
plug-in keyboard for the iPad pro we
support those as well if you have an
iPhone and an Apple watch we all have a
watch app around which you can use to
deploy you your deployments over to the
Apple watch and view them over there on
Android we require Android 4.1 that's
first jellybean or later and also any
device that has a gigabyte or more
memory such as the galaxy s3 or later
obviously the app will run much better
on newer devices in the galaxy s3 on
both apps you need a cloud account you
do not need to have a paid account a
free one is okay if you have a private
cloud then the applications support
connecting to your private cloud you
connect to the private cloud by changing
a setting inside the Settings app on iOS
and on Android there's a control on the
login screen which you use to change
your server and both applications
require a network connection they do not
work offline here are some of the things
you can do inside the cloud apps you can
connect to either Wolfram cloud comm or
you connect connect to a private cloud
server you can browse your files and
folders you can create new notebooks
unless you are on Mathematica online
viewer and then we block you from doing
that you can edit your existing
notebooks you can fill out instant api's
and instant web forms you can magnify
your content grow it or shrink the fonts
you can copy and paste your texts and
images from other iOS applications you
can rename objects you can delete
objects and we also have an online
documentation browser which you can use
and to help you do your coding inside
the notebook you can edit text you can
insert control equals boxes you can
create and evaluate cells we have
autocomplete on both iOS and Android we
have function templates on iOS only this
feature will be rolled out to Android
pretty soon and you can also insert
images that are taken by the camera or
if
the photo gallery you can also copy and
paste cells now some of the things you
can't do in the cloud apps is you cannot
create new folders you can't move
objects between folders you can do that
in the player app which we'll get to a
little bit later you cannot create or
edit scheduled tasks within the GUI
interface you can still do them from the
Wolfram language code you can't share
files from other users quite like you
can on the desktop you can't resize 2d
objects yet we're working on that
you can't rotate 3d objects but you can
under play your app which I'll cover a
little later and anything that obvious
for obvious reasons won't work in the
cloud like system modeler integration
arduino link or other connected devices
that won't work as well a question that
we frequently get from our users is ok
so I launched your app now why did your
app need my phone's location well first
of all we don't need your phone's
location both apps can use your phone's
location and the reason why we do it is
to initialize the value of here inside
the kernel as well as the we also get
your time zone in order to initialize
the local time zone symbol and we we do
those things for queries that will use
your location in some interesting way if
you don't want to provide us that
information that's fine you don't have
to provide us with that information
however if you try doing something that
is geo sensitive then we fall back on
geo IP and if you're on a Wi-Fi network
that may or may not work if you're on a
mobile phone network then that will
probably place you in the middle of a
cornfield in Kansas we will also ask you
for your camera or photo library
permission in order to insert images
into notebooks and forms you don't need
to give us that but if you want to paste
an image you have to give us that
permission all communication between
your device and our server is encrypted
and any day that you do send us is
governed by our privacy policy in the
way you view our privacy policy is if
you're just signing up for an account we
have a link inside our the signup form
that allows you to read our privacy
policy if you're already signed in you
can once you bring up the application
you can touch the hamburger button which
is the button in the top left corner of
the application and you can touch your
name or logo this is wolfram player
inside the player app and then we have a
link in there it's where you can watch
our you can view our privacy policy for
yourself all right let's take a look and
I'm going to switch views now
you
alright now I've already started the
cloud app up so this is what my home
screen looks like I'm going to touch the
hamburger button here so you can see all
of our different navigation options you
can choose deployments for example to
view your instant web forms I don't
believe I have any on this account oh I
do have a few but what I'm gonna do here
is I'm gonna go back to my home and then
I'm going to create a new notebook and
can you see the controls there at the
bottom okay this is what you do to
create new cells or do navigation when
you're when you've got a insertion point
selected like that so I'm going to touch
new cell here and we have several
different options for your new cells I'm
going to just choose style text here and
there are a few more options inside
style text I'm going to choose title and
I'm going to type a title
and just to show you our system does
support Unicode so I'm going to touch
the globe button down here in the corner
here and I'm going to choose this option
here that says Japanese alphabet nihongo
kana and I'm just going to type C suebob
dashi that means wonderful in Japanese
and I'll switch back to Latin and I'll
come down here and create an input cell
and I'll type something into the input
cell to show you some of our new user
assistance features so I'm going to type
the NIP and you can see as I type down
here you can see this is the
autocomplete over here this bar right
here and now let's say I don't remember
how to use manipulate well on the
desktop you have function templates to
deal with that and on mobile we also add
function templates so I'm going to touch
and hold here and get an option here the
one button on the right will bring up
the documentation for that particular
symbol I'll go bring it back and then
the button on the left will allow us to
insert a function template and I can
type something here so Oh
plus a x5 if it's PI and close and I can
touch all here I need to close now you
can touch one of these here and insert
so I'm gonna go to a from I don't know
negative 10 to positive you can also
slide like that and okay valuate
spin-spin-spin okay here's my evaluation
and I can drag the slider here and it's
it works pretty well I'd say it's a
little bit choppy but that's just
because we're going back and forth with
the server just to get images from the
server in order to display them here
let's show you something else I'll touch
input cell again and this time I'm going
to insert a photo and I'm going to use
edge detect on a photo I'm going to
touch the button here above the evaluate
button here that's going to insert a
photograph and you can see here you can
either take a picture with one of your
cameras you can go to the photo library
or a feature we have from the Wolfram
Alpha app that we put in here you can
use the last photo taken I'll choose
photo library just for now let's take a
look at my photos mmm
i tawt i taw a puttytat i did i did taw
a puttytat
I'm gonna evaluate that my cat's name is
the edge by the way so I'm using edge
detect too deep
hecht edge okay
now I could be up here all day but I've
got another app to show you so I'm gonna
exit out of here and since this is a new
notebook it's going to ask me to rename
my notebook and I'm gonna type z1
I'm putting the Z up front so that it
will appear at the bottom of my file
list so that you can see the file as we
were leaving out here you can see that
it appeared down there in the bottom
right corner and alright I I think
that's enough for the cloud app let me
switch back here so
you
you
let me talk a little bit about well from
player for iOS where from player allows
you to view and interact with your
notebooks but not edit them it works
both offline and online the system
requirements generally the same as the
cloud app although you don't need a
network connection so why use the
wolfram player app and not the cloud app
well it supports pinch zoom you can
rotate your 3d graphics you can cut you
can move your locators around and it
works all as fast as your CPU will allow
it to run it supports connecting to
multiple cloud accounts at once you can
connect to the different accounts on the
same server or you can connect to
multiple servers if you have both the
public and private cloud account for
example you can import to your notebooks
from a third-party file cloud such as
Dropbox or onedrive the Google Drive
does not work quite yet and I'll show
you in a bit here you can also transfer
files between the cloud servers and the
local device you can even transfer files
between cloud accounts if you've got
multiple different accounts at once and
it all works in the background so if
you're on a particularly slow network
connection what you can do is if you're
downloading a large notebook you can
just start the download put the app in
the background go look at cat photos
catch a Pokemon whatever you like to do
when you're not using the one of the
player app and then you can come back
and hopefully it'll be done also the
player app supports slide over and split
view if you have an iPad error or later
so why not use the wolfram player app
well you can't edit or evaluate and also
not all kernel functionality is
available in the player app most of it
is but anything that depends on j-link
is just going to fail in the player app
and the reason why is because there is
no Java Runtime on iOS ok let's switch
back here and let's
you
all right when you first start the
player app here you get our welcome
notebook and let me show you how to
manipulate files here you can either use
the select button which is in near the
top right corner there or you can long
press on there and it'll automatically
select it and move into selection mode
from here I can share it and this works
like the sharing window on every other
iOS app and this is how we use airdrop
in order to transfer the file you can
also you send it to email or copy it to
a cloud service whatever shows up in
your sharing window normally one other
thing we can do is we can move it to the
cloud and the way I do that is I touch
all locations back here to back one out
I was on on this device a moment ago
I'll just touch my cloud account here
and there are my cloud files there now
notice that the button changed slightly
it was moved just a moment ago so it
moves the file on local accounts but
once you move it off server to somewhere
I'm it changes to copy instead so I'm
gonna copy that and it'll copy it to my
home folder there other things you can
do you can also rename it or delete it
from here now delete is a little white
lie and when we're browsing a cloud file
system because when you press the delete
button we're actually sending your
documents to the trashcan rather than
deleting it outright but on a local
device if you press the delete button
and you confirm they are you sure then
if you delete it it's gone so I'll so
you can see here that I have multiple
accounts signed in at once and I can
sign in two more by touching this add
another cloud account button here at the
bottom and we get to the sign in window
and here's how you change servers as
well you touch the cloud server button
and I'm going to cancel out of these you
can import files from third-party clouds
now if you're using iOS 10 or earlier
you'll see your cloud services here on
Iowa
eleven changes to browse and I'll touch
that and here's how you get your
accounts from other other places this is
the problem that we're having with the
Google Drive that is a actual notebook
and it's not letting us select that we
know about this but on iCloud Drive and
Dropbox it works but let's switch back
to the cloud here I'll choose home and
here's the document that we just made
okay that's pretty smooth because it's
running locally and you can also magnify
it make it larger and this button up
here's for documentation so you can get
to the back to the documentation Center
inside the player app as well and then
we also have a some other features in
here you can rename and delete from
within the notebook or you can touch
download to device and that's going to
copy it to my local file system this is
also kind of a little white lie because
we already downloaded it we're just
copying the file over or not okay I'm
not sure what happened there but anyway
I think that's about everything so let
me now take you to
all right now if you have an iPhone on
you please point your QR code reader at
the screen and this is how you this will
take you to the iTunes Store where you
can download our app and you can see
here that I put the warm language code
up front so you know I'm not rickrolling
you okay I see a few phones up here
Android users you might want to prime
your QR code reading app because I'm
going to get to you next okay I see
that's going down I'll switch to Android
Play or Android users put your devices
in the air and point them at the screen
like you actually do care okay I got one
I got one more apt to go through but I
can take questions at this time if any
of you have any questions Fahim well we
do allow evaluations if you use a button
or if you use the dynamic command or
manipulate or anything that would go
through the kernel we do support those
evaluations you just can't evaluate in
or edit inside the application because
we haven't programmed that in yet
it is my understanding that they allow
interpreted languages now just not
compiled ones okay I see hands going
down now so iOS users you might want to
point your phones at the screen again
this is linked to the wolfram player app
now the wolfram player app is quite
large I think it's more than a quarter
gig in size so you might want to be on a
Wi-Fi device for this one yes sir
no but that would be an interesting
product idea please send a suggestion to
us yes
so I don't believe we support current
image yet on mobile cloud notebooks I
don't know what it would take to get
that in the player application I mean
I'm really not sure so come back next
year
now player player by definition is a
reader so just like it is on the desktop
you can't you know open up paper and
just
what's that
you wanna when we go back okay sure
yes sir
maybe come back next year
yes sir
mm-hmm so you're looking for an SDK then
contact us somebody from our
partnerships might be able to assist you
with that I don't have any comment on
that my but I don't work on that yes sir
yes yes yes sir okay that's another
great feature suggestion can you send us
send it to our tech support department
please
[Music]
oh that's interesting yeah again contact
our tech support and send us as many
details as you can we'd like to help you
with that
yes sir you want to switch between the
two I don't think we have any way of met
of automatically doing that but you can
certainly manually do that because you
can have the player app running in slide
over for example while the cloud app
runs in the foreground you could do that
just not automatically switching I
believe we're out of time so if you have
any other questions please contact me
thank you
[Applause]